ancien conseiller spécial de nicolas
sarkozy à l'elysée député ump des
yvelines henri guaino est notre invité
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 avec l'
agence france-presse
et dailymotion avec dans un instant donc
perrine tarneaud et puis nadège pull
jacques de la fp vous êtes avec nous
dans cet entre-deux en quelque sorte un
entre la nomination l'arrivée de manuel
valls à matignon après la déroute
électorale du ps aux élections
municipales et puis il annonce d'un
gouvernement de combat un gouvernement
resserré comme l'a annoncé françois
hollande
d'abord est-ce que vous souhaiter bonne
chance à manuel valls qui ouvre donc
l'acte 2 du quinquennat
est ce que vous le souhaitez de réussir
bien sûr comment ne pas souhaiter au
gouvernement de mon pays de réussir
maintenant j'ai des doutes sur sur sa
capacité à répondre aux défis auxquels
il se trouve confronté après les
élections de dimanche dernier du
dimanche précédent des jeux sur sa
personne non non des doutes parlant de
lui un peu oui vous êtes un qu'il a de
meilleur à tôt par exemple que jean marc
ayrault pris les traits il est différent
mais ce n'est pas le premier ministre
qui fait la politique de la france c'est
le président de la république
donc on va on va voir ce que ce que ce
tandem arriva à faire ma phase iib gens
si j'en juge par l'allocution du
président de la république hier soir le
défi n'est pas près d'être relevé l'idée
la feuille de route aller plus vite et
plus loin et toujours poursuivre le
redressement est ce qu a dit d'ailleurs
se vendent aujourd'hui il a dit on
continue et on amplifie bon si c'est ça
la réponse au message compte envoyer les
français au cours des deux tours des
élections municipales
je crains qu'il y est un profond
malentendu est français on dit ça peut
pas continuer comme ça on change de
premier ministre en disant ça continue
voilà je pense que ça va pas très bien
finir 6
le gouvernement et le président de la
république restent sur 7 sur cette ligne
de conduite
et si vous avez remarqué que le peuple
français étaient en colère si vous ne
l'avez pas vu renvoyer le résultat des
élections
une immense abstention qui n'est pas une
abstention d'indifférence mais de rejet
une montée des extrêmes qui est tout de
même extrêmement inquiétante et qui est
très forte
cette colère elle ne peut pas elle peut
pas rester contenue si on répond à un
peuple qui dit changer tout on continue
on va bien compris la leçon
les premiers visés bien sûr d'abord on a
entendu françois hollande reconnaître
que le message était fort et aujourd'hui
même manuel valls dit qu'il a entendu de
la part du peuple français comme vous
dites il ya eu une demande de justice
sociale dans celui-ci on est homo ça ce
sont des mots il est moi je retiens il a
dit on continue et on amplifie voilà on
continue et on amplifie les mots 10
gbits/s qui veut le dire à dire qu'on
continue comme avant parce que vous ne
vous fait les s'était pas venir - comme
jean pierre raffarin
par exemple qui dit qu'avec manuel valls
et françois hollande la plus choisie la
droite que la gauche que la gauche que
de la gauche - le mois la droite à
gauche la gauche de la droite et gauche
de la gauche comme ça m'intéresse pages
ça n'intéresse personne d'ailleurs
un personne vrai c'est une ligne que
d'être une incarnation n'est pas tout à
fait la même avec un match comme manuel
valls n'est nommé daniël a été fixé hier
par le président de la république vous
avez écouté son discours
si monsieur valls a compris ce que le
président attend dé lui tant mieux parce
que moi je n'ai rien compris entre le
président hier et manuel valls
aujourd'hui la seule chose qu'on peut
retenir c'est qu'en gros continuent et
que simplement on va servir un peu plus
de clientèle ici ou là on va donner un
peu plus aux un peu moins aux autres
voilà sans savoir d'ailleurs comment on
va financer ce qu'on va donner sans voir
où est la ligne où est la cohérence on
est toujours confronté au même problème
depuis le début de ce quinquennat et il
n'y a pas de ligne il n'y a pas de cap
mais on dit sans arrêt qu on maintient
le cap mais quel cap vous savez si tous
les marins du monde depuis le début des
temps avait eu la même définition du cap
pense que il tournerait iraient beaucoup
de bateaux qui tournerait encore au
milieu de l'océan depuis des semaines
tandis que romain est lui-même en
quelque sorte c'est ça mais oui mais
c'est dans la vème république et avec le
quinquennat donc avec le quinquennat le
président fait tout ou presque tout donc
si président ne change pas ne se réforme
pas lui même espace rire mais néanmoins
avec la personnalité forte de manuel
valls est ce que on peut s'interroger
sur la nature de la cohabitation avec le
mondialisation ça c'est à langlade
explique alain vème république il ya pas
de cohabitation dans la vème république
c'est le président qui décide c'est le
président qui est la clé de voûte des
institutions
c'est le président qui est l'élu du
peuple donc c'est le sait l'homme de la
nation
y'a pas de cohabitation il n'y a aucune
espèce d'égalité ni de rivalité une
concurrence possible et quand il en ait
eu ou quand un premier ministre à la
velléité de ans n'entre en concurrence
avec le président de la république ça
finit toujours de la même manière le
premier s'en va rappelez-vous jacques
chaban-delmas rappelez-vous jacques
chirac
rappelez-vous michel rocard voilà c'est
les choses se passent toujours de cette
façon c'est déjà écrit là puisque j'ai
entendu hier soir et est aujourd'hui
l'avenir me paraît déjà écrit mais
l'avenir c'est pas à l'avenir entre les
deux hommes c'est l'avenir entre le
président de la république et son
gouvernement et sa majorité et le peuple
et le peuple français et allemands quand
même sur sur manuel valls que je me
souviens que nicolas sarkozy avait ou
aurait alors à l'époque proposé
une ouverture vers manuel valls un
recrutement éventuellement de manuel
valls dans le cadre de l'ouverture
je vous pose la question c'est que vous
pouvez confirmer jusqu'à montre
l'intérêt qu'il a pu ceci ne confirme
rien du tout mais j'ai de l'estimé pour
manuel valls mais je pense qu'ils la
mission qui lui est confiée est
aujourd'hui une mission impossible
alors je n'observe mission impossible
d'abord aucun aucun premier ministre
sitôt nommé n'a suscité autant de
critiques et de réticences dans sa
propre majorité
bon monsieur mamère a eu même cette
formule et disait de monsieur valls
s'était pas le plus grand rassembleur
mais plus grand diviseur de la gauche
bon alors je suis bien avec mélenchon
l'a dit jean luc mélenchon l'a dit aussi
mais beaucoup d'autres l'ont dit
certains publics d'autres à vancouver je
suis bien certain qu'il aura une
majorité au parlement
s'ils posent la question de confiance je
suis bien certain que il arrivera à
faire entrer au gouvernement
probablement toutes les composantes
qu'il souhaite de sa majorité
c'est une question de prix le problème
le problème est de savoir ce qu'il est
prêt à faire comme concession à tous
ceux qui dans la majorité sont en
désaccord avec lui ou en tout cas ne
voulait pas de lui afin de lui demander
d'être lui-même a tempéré vous saluer
mais non c'est intéressant aussi pour
être acceptable par tout le monde si
pour arriver à rassembler tant bien que
mal et plutôt mal que bien la majorité
il
et fait des concessions extravagantes je
pense pas que ça va améliorer la
situation à leur gouvernement
la situation du justement pour préserver
la majorité présidentielle actuelle
manuel valls a très tôt consulter et
rencontrer les responsables d'europe
écologie les verts on sait que cécile
duflot ee pascal canfin ne feront pas du
parti du gouvernement en raison d'un
problème de ligne en t-il dit néanmoins
il ya des avancées qui se dessine avec
l'entrée probable de personnalité que
l'on ressente la tentation tentation est
forte c'est certain si eux puisqu'on
leur offre beaucoup
la tentation est encore plus forte bon
mais est il bien raisonnable honnêtement
de confier aux écologistes si j'en crois
ce que j'entends à la radio et à la
télévision
un grand ministère regroupant l'écologie
les transports l'énergie
voilà jusqu'où iront les concessions de
monsieur valls à la gauche de la gauche
du parti socialiste aux écologistes
voilà jusqu'où jusqu'où ira-t-il c'est
quand même une vraie une vraie question
ce soir
alors selon pascal canfin ccim du tout
se serait vu proposer le poste de numéro
deux du gouvernement justement pour
qu'elle reste un oui je pense que la
meilleure solution aurait été de la
nommer premier ministre non pourquoi pas
on sait pas chaque été fait par le
président de la république avait parié
l'anc a donné tant que tant qu'à
distribuer les postes de cette façon
c'est le problème du président de la
république et de celui de cette majorité
le président de la république est un
homme de la quatrième république c'est
un homme qui ne sait pas gouverner
autrement qu'en marchant dans avec les
uns et les autres
donc il sert des clientèles y sert des
il se comporte comme le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste avec les
courants les sous-courants les
sensibilités diverses du parti
socialiste rassemblée la famille me
semble est une chose faire du
clientélisme en est une tout autre et
lui fait du client t il pour décrire une
parti socialiste oui il serre les
clientèles dans la société
les minorités agissantes et communautés
tout le monde à tout le monde a sa part
et puis dans la façon de gérer
la majorité et le gouvernement il le
fait comme faisait le premier comme il
le faisait quand il était premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste françois
mitterrand avait compris que il ya une
différence entre la fonction
présidentielle et celle de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
mais manifestement ça n'est pas encore
le cas de françois hollande mais on peut
pas gouverner comme ça pourquoi il tente
de quoi que dans le précédent
gouvernement
pas simplement parce que monsieur
ayrault aurait manqué d'autorité mais
parce que le monsieur ayrault était fait
d'ailleurs sur le même modèle que
monsieur comme monsieur hollande c'est
100 m de la quatrième république
chaque ministre alassane la navale
chaque ministre avait le sentiment
d'être le porte parole de la clientèle
est un homme de la quatrième république
non je crois pas que ce soit l'homme de
la quatrième république mais il entre
dans un système où l'impulsion la ligne
la politique sont définis par le chef de
l'état et le chef de l'état est un homme
d un quatrième craignaient une révision
à la baisse du pacte de compétitivité
pour les entreprises non mais moi je
sais toujours pas ce qui va sortir donc
on verra quand ça sortira ça ne
ressemblera sûrement rien à ce que le
président de la république avait promis
voilà lancés comme d'habitude
bon alors il y aura pas de duras pas de
contrepartie parce que c'était farfelue
mais ça veut dire que le président avait
raconté n'importe quoi mais plus vite
plus loin ou ou et est ce que les
français on dit aller plus vite plus
loin en continuant exactement ce qu'on
faisait je moi je ne sais pas je sais
pas quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement je ne sais pas quelle est
sa politique économique et de la demande
on supprime toutes les exonérations de
charge tous les allègements le lendemain
n'est dans la politique de l'offre et
puis le surlendemain on se dit peut-être
qu'il faut revenir à la demande et
l'économie ça se fait avec l'offre et la
demande où est la stratégie d'offre et
de demande où est la politique
macroéconomique du gouvernement je n'en
sais rien personne n'en sait rien mais
c'est bien et c'est bien le problème
il n'y a toujours pas de cap vous
appartenez à parler un parti qui
préconise plus de 100 milliards ça
écouter vous n'avez pas invité mon parti
et moi on m'avait invité - oui voilà
donc il ya des gens dont il ya déjà une
éthique et politique à régler alors
alors je suis profondément libre mais
profondément leurs désirs vous croyez
aux 50 milliards d'euros d'économie à
dauphine je ne crois pas aux 50
milliards d'euros
et je crois pas non plus aux 100
milliards d'euros non parce que je pense
que c'est nous sommes nous sommes sommes
enfermés dans une façon d'aborder
l'économie qui est sans issue voilà qui
est sans issue pourquoi parce que la
finance publique ne se rétabliront pas
en faisant en comparant n'importe
comment dans les dépenses du jour au
lendemain d'ailleurs c'est impossible
personne ne l'a ni a réussi et quand on
fait à n'importe quel prix ça fait de
tels dégâts que de toute façon ça cause
des déficits et donc nous nous
rétablirons nos finances publiques
si nous comprenons enfin que les l'état
nos finances publiques et le résultat la
conséquence de ce qui se passe dans
l'économie dans la société
c'est en me remettant de l'ordre dans
l'économie dans la société que nous
arriverons à c'est bien de finir ma
musique d'accord ma dernière question en
lien avec le gouvernement vous avez des
savanes en fait une des politiques
d'austérité les pires depuis le début de
la vème république
avec les résultats que l'on sait c'est à
dire qu'on n'arrive pas à maîtriser les
déficits n'avaient même pas maîtriser la
dépense tout en faisant une politique
d'austérité
on est enfermé dans des quadras
justement terrible vous avez dit ce que
vous pensez de le maintien éventuel de
lune ministre écologique dans le
gouvernement aurait guaino est-ce que
vous souhaiter le maintien par exemple
d'arnaud montebourg
non moi je suis sur laquelle vous pouvez
voir des positions communes en parler et
manger postérité l'euro beaucoup
d'estimé pour andres bon mais je suis
pas en train de moi je ne suis pas
habilité à bien sûr à baba pour céder la
10eme territories et a commenté aussi
non nous ne suis pas un commentateur de
la vie poétique
c'est le président de la république qui
choisit son gouvernement c'est lui qui
nomme le premier ministre et chacun des
ministres individus
le mans c'est le président de la
république et on décide c'est son choix
voilà je n'ai moi je n'ai pas de
commentaires à faire à jouer sauf que je
constate que pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune réponse au changement demandé
avec force par les français très bien
voilà on a bien compris le message de
cette première partie d'émission a
ajouté kim a beaucoup beaucoup changé
deux choses qui m'ont choqué hier la
façon dont s'est passée l'annoncent delà
de la démission de monsieur ayrault et
de la nomination de monsieur valls c'est
qu'on pousse est contraire à tous les
usages de la vème république il ya bien
des ordres dans les institutions qui
devient extrêmement temps ça monte
inquiétant bon il est aujourd'hui
moi j'ai trouvé curieux que monsieur
valls pour ses premiers mots à la nation
en tant que premier ministre je suis
socialiste ou sommes socialistes et un
premier ministre il n'est pas socialiste
il n'est pas de droite il n'est pas de
gauche il est premier ministre tous les
français et pourra républicains comme
monsieur valls ça me surprend beaucoup
et ça m'inquiète un peu pour l'avenir
voilà je crois que si on si on est
décidé à gouverner en dressant une
france de golf contre une france de
droite une france socialiste contre une
france qui compte c'est l'engagement
quand on est pour les mines un seul un
seul c'est un engagement vis-à-vis de la
france
et pareil pour le président de la
république prévue la socialiste tout le
monde connaît l'histoire de monsieur
valls ou le cône et celle de monsieur de
monsieur hollande y a pas besoin de
rappeler l'appartenance à un parti et on
a compris votre message principal
ce premier quart d'heure de l'émission
régionaux pour vous c'est mission
impossible pour ce nouveau duo de
l'exécutif nadège pourchasse tous à la
très dure promotionnelle ça c'est sûr
nadège pdg de l'aef paix arrive donc
nous allons maintenant évoquer la
situation à l'ump excuse après la vague
bleue on a noté chez certains de vos
amis d'ailleurs une manière de réserve
pas de triomphalisme à votre sanction
pour françois hollande est il synonyme
de victoire par défaut pour l'opposition
faustine saint geniès au groupe ump du
sénat ce matin on savoure la victoire on
se félicite et on espère repartir sur de
bonnes bases
la vague bleue serait-elle un remède de
choc pour faire oublier les conflits à
l'ump
c'est une victoire éclatante
le mp se porte bien malgré tout le
bashing comme on dit aujourd'hui tous
les jours tous les jours tous les jours
c'était en miettes
eh bien non le grand gagnant de ces
municipales c'est bien sûr jean françois
copé lui qui il ya encore quinze jours
et est empêtrée dans l'affairé bygmalion
il aimerait bien surfer sur la vague
bleue et réduire ses rivaux au silence
au moins dans l'immédiat
de son côté françois fillon avait promis
de lui demander des comptes
il a tenu parole et vient de réclamer
plus de transparence à l'ump l'ump où
l'on préfère éviter de rouvrir les
plaies pour se concentrer sur les enjeux
de l'élection
je pense que d'une part l'unité de la
direction de l'ump dans ce contexte
n'était pas facile a été assumée par
tous dans tous nos meetings dans de
nombreuses réunions communes mais aussi
une certaine forme de sobriété
on n'a pas triomphé on a conscience de
la gravité dans le camp de jean françois
copé
on met en garde les éventuels fauteurs
de troubles nous avons largement gagné
ni nos élus ni nos militants nos
électeurs ne veulent aujourd'hui du sang
à l'ump ce qu'ils peuvent venir
protester contesté critiqué vont
apparaître comme mauvais joueur et comme
hors du cadre
et nous le dirons clairement
une ump qui veut donc apparaître uni en
vue des prochaines échéances
sénatoriales en 2014 et régionales en
ces résultats on a vu conforte le
président de votre parti jean françois
copé
elles vont à l'égard des chefs s'est
terminé alors à vous dire que la guerre
des chefs soient terminés je l'espère je
l'espère je suis pas sûr que cette cette
municipale va vous permettre d'enterrer
tout les haches de guerre avec laurel
d'ego les ambitions vous vous rappelez
vous un tel parti socialiste à la même
époque
après la défaite de 2007 à are su après
tout la politique vous savez c'est
humain ça se fait avec avec des gens qui
ont des sentiments qui ont des ambitions
mais à votre avis qui tire le plus de
profit de cette victoire
nicolas sarkozy puisqu'il faut six ans
par nicolas sarkozy qui les reçoit en
tous les cas killer qui les appels mais
monsieur guaino va sans doute nous
l'expliqué jean-françois copé juppé
françois fillon
et puis on peut aussi citer laurent
wauquiez a brillamment réélu lui aussi
au puy en velay xavier bertrand lui
aussi réélu bruno le maire barrois
françois baroin a lui aussi
alors à qui ça profite à tous ceux qui
ont été élus mona ils ont été élus ou
réélus bravo est ce que jean françois
copé est plus que jamais le chef de
l'opposition n'y a pas de chef de
l'opposition
il n'y a pas de charges y a pas de chef
de l'opposition beaucoup de monsieur
sarkozy a donc bien sûr parce qu'il y
avait un chef
cet intérêt à disputer malavoy la fhf ça
se décrète pas il se fait pas non plus
de gagner
il ya un président de l'ump il n'est pas
contesté dans sa fonction aujourd'hui ça
fait pas ça fait pas un chef ou alors il
y en a une multitude monde et chef de
lui-même enfin c'est qu'est ce qui fait
la différence entre un copé est un
sarkozy parents qu'est ce qui fait
monsieur sarkozy était un chef de se
signer cela mystérieuse alchimie
du charisme du chef voilà il ya temps en
temps émergent quelqu'un qui s'impose à
tous les autres et qui est capable
d'entraîner tout le monde de faire la
synthèse de surmonter les contradictions
d'haïti qui a quelqu'un qui a acquis une
légitimité qui apparaît comme évidente à
tout le monde c'était le cas ça a été le
cas pour nicolas sarkozy
pour l'instant il a laissé un grand vide
en partant ce vide n'est pas remplie
salé faire un jour à personne que de le
constater
est-ce que lui pas des traces de
cannabis fillon monsieur juppé monsieur
bertrand
il ya tous les autres s'ils ont un chef
et pas plus à monsieur copé d'ailleurs
y'a pas de chef
bon alors il n'y a pas de chef alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer en 2010 c'est
parce que on veut déjà dans les starting
blocks un autre parti pour 2017
on prend on parle de préparer
l'alternance est un mot qui a été
employé par monsieur juppé par monsieur
copé par monsieur fillon tout le monde
veut préparer l'alternance chez vous bon
ça non mais c'est normal seulement 10 m
est ce qui nous mène à 2017 nous fait
évidemment penser au président à
l'ancien président pardon à l'ancien
président nicolas sarkozy et donc aux
primaires parce qu'il faudra bien
départager tout ce petit monde bien sûr
contre la primaire la caisse des métiers
contre la primaire
la question est là alors qu'est-ce que
vous attaquez ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui il faut une primaire qu'est
ce qui va se passer parce que moi je
suis contre le principe des primaires
qui est totalement contradictoire avec
les principes de la vème république
maintenant avec maintenant parce que la
démocratie c'est d'aller devant le
peuple
il ya une élection présidentielle à deux
tours qui se fait qui est qui qui permet
au président de la république d'être
l'élu de la nation la démocratie c'est
ça le reste ce sont les affaires des
partis mon oud et quand méme et la
démocratie avec deux tours d'élection
elle est parfaitement respectée là son
compte démocratie c'est pas en faisant
quatre tours en rajoutant de deux tours
de primaires au 2 tour des
présidentielles qu'on est plus
démocratique ou alors il n'y a pas de
grandes démocraties dans le monde parce
que ce sera c'est le seul pays au monde
à 4,34 tout quatre tours d'élection le
seul qui se passe alors simplement tout
le monde a voulu des primaires il y aura
donc des primaires à l'exception de
dans le cas où nicolas sarkozy
déciderait parce que les circonstances
l'exigent parce que les français leur
assentiment que les français ont besoin
de lui
déciderait de se représenter voilà moi
je ne je n'imagine pas un instant
nicolas sarkozy passant par l'étape des
primaires pour se présenter devant les
français
si il veut se présenter il se présente
dirais que fillon va laisser faire ça
ils vont laisser terrassement vous
croyez vraiment que que tout ceci a une
importance quelconque
voilà vous vous croyez vraiment que
fillon qui ancien premier ministre
monsieur copé du président de l'ump n'a
pas d'importance avant nous annoncer ça
dépend c'est monsieur sarkozy à mes yeux
ne peut pas passer par la case des
primaires donc à mes yeux
il décide de se représenter il ira
directement devant les français dira
voilà je suis candidat en voilà les
raisons en voici les raisons et gmt au
race déterminée pour savoir si elle ne
soutient pas et je peux vous faire un
pari c'est qu'elle ne soutiendra et
renoncera la procédure des primaires
mais cette question ne se posera même
pas causeront ils apposeront ils
attendront la réponse très longtemps la
réponse elle deviendra des militants des
adhérents mais moi je trouve que la
démocratie c'est de cette affaire enfin
c'est une blague
mira de la démocratie vous verrez soit
le signe infaillible de la démocratie
oui c'est une blague
est-ce que vous pensez que tous les
éléments tout l'évolution de la
situation que vous avez n'est que manuel
valls était dans une mission impossible
vont forcément conduire une envie une
décision candidature de nicolas sonore
sans rien mais j'y reviens il ne s'y
serait une serait pas beau s'il décide
d'être candidat qui l'aï sans commencer
par s'enfermer dans son camp c'est tout
problème des primaires bon alors on a
décidé de les faire encore une fois à
l'exception de sa candidature s'il n'est
pas candidat on les fera mais ça oblige
les gens à s'enfermer dans leur temps ça
les oblige à se durcir
ça les oblige à se fermer aux autres et
le président de la république c'est tout
le contraire
d'ailleurs on oublie toujours le cas de
monsieur hollande j'ai regardé et il a
été élu c'est fantastique ça a permis de
sélectionner le pire président de la
vème république a encore une fois encore
une fois le celui selon pierre le pire
le pire a pour l'instant c'est le pire
on n'a pas fait pire c'est moi je n'ai
jamais vu pire jamais vu le pays dans un
état pareil si vous avez un exemple
depuis cinquante-huit d'une situation
pareille où les français sont autant
divisé où tout s'effondre ou les
institutions elles mêmes sont ébranlées
alors dites moi quelle période
quel moment quel moment de notre
histoire depuis 58 à dire depuis le
moment où grâce au général de gaulle on
a évité de sombrer dans la guerre civile
expliquez moi quand on n'a vu non
assisté à une situation pareille
intel nos francs
politique institutionnel économique
sociale sociétale puisque c'est d'avoir
un cours commun un possible sauveur si
je puis employé ce moment là je sais pas
si c'est un sauveur mais peut-être qu'à
un certain moment il apparaîtra beaucoup
de français que c'est une solution mais
nous verrons les circonstances en
décideront et lui-même me prendra sa
décision et le moment venu ils vous
envoient vous en voulez parler qu'est-ce
qu'il vous dit oui mais il s'agit d'un
principe je respecte ça veut dire ça je
ne parle jamais du contenu de mes
conversations et qui connaissent alors
qu'à propos de recours il ya deux ans
d'études chargé d'un pull back comme je
n'ai pas l'habitude de les enregistrer
pour les rendre publiques
attention certains peuvent le faire à
roodepoort en double raison pour garder
dans l'intimité ce qui relève de
l'intimité
oui mais et vous bien sûr on parle de
recours monsieur juppé se place lui-même
comme un recours bien sûr j'ai entendu
dire qu'on n'était pas en 2017
ce n'est pas le moment écoutant on va
déjà rajouterai vous poser une question
aux part souvent dans la presse
monsieur manuel valls qui est maintenant
premier ministre à nicolas sarkozy
c'est d'ailleurs là une demain de
charlie hebdo vers une
on a une belle caricature de manuel
valls avec comme légende
et bien voilà sarkozy est à matignon et
vous qui êtes restés proches de l'ancien
président
ça vous énerve ça vous flatte une
comparaison flatteuse bien mais je
n'étais pas rendu compte que nicolas
sarkozy était en train de maintenir ou
non les répondants souvent ils sont
dynamiques tous les deux parce qu'ils
ont rêvé d'être une proximité
idéologique c'est parfois ben je sais
pas nous verrons bien
oh c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy a porté
comme comme idée comme principe vers ce
qu'il a fait comme politique
comment il a affronté l'épreuve du
pouvoir et de la crise
pour l'instant on ne sait pas comment
manuel valls se comporterait dans des
circonstances analogues et dans 10
et la place qu'occupe et nicolas sarkozy
je rappelle que il est rentré à l'hôtel
matignon pas à l'elysée aujourd'hui nous
verrons mais moi je moi je trouve les
deux hommes très dissemblables même si
il ya chez manuel valls une énergie une
volonté et son ambition
oui m'enfin soit l'ambition vous savez
c'est la chose la mieux partagée du web
elle m'a toujours affirmé on est souvent
très affirmée la wii est bon pour en
revenir à l'ump ce matin vous étiez au
petit déjeuner ce week end alors
peut-être eu de nevers entendu parler de
près de la demande de monsieur sion qui
a redemandé en fait ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il est fait il a
redemandé des comptes la transparence
des comptes de l'ump à monsieur copé qui
d'ailleurs lui a fait répondre loup lui
a répondu qu il était bien d'accord pour
la transparence de ses comptes
est ce que tout ça cette nature à à à
remettre le bazar dans votre parti a je
crois qu'on peut employer un auto parce
que ça a été le bazar ah bon le groupe
parlementaire
ça aussi c'était unis pas de manque de
transparence et bien sûr c'est tout à
fait légitime et d'ailleurs les comptes
des partis sont parfaitement transparent
vous savez c'est il ya la commission des
financements de la vie publique qui
contrôle qui peut rendre public tout ce
qu'elle veut bon et on ne peut lui
refuser aucun document les comptes sont
certifiés par deux commissaires aux
comptes indépendants
voilà donc moi je moi je suis pour que
tout se à titre personnel pour que tous
ceux qui veulent avoir accès aux comptes
puissent avoir accès aux pièces et une
commission ad-hoc au sein même de votre
parti qui est chargé justement de
vérifier les comptes à winnezeele
expliqué sur internent bon mais mais
après s'il doit y avoir des débats sur
les sur les comptes il ya des choses qui
font aujourd'hui en tous les cas la
question du début il ya un risque de
guerre interne si vous changez rien me
font me demandé aux protagonistes des
guerres des guerres du passé vous êtes
vigueur mais je suis pas dans la tête
des uns des autres moi moi ça
m'intéresse pas de la politique comme ça
mais d'expulsion m'intéresse pas du tout
voilà ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est le débat d'idées c'est des
transgressions intellectuelle c'est
comment comment on peut gouverner notre
pays dans l'état où il se trouve
comment on peut affronter toutes les
crises auxquelles il est confronté
l'alternance changé comment on peut
changer notre façon de faire de la
politique et le contenu de nos
politiques
est-ce qu'on va continuer avec la
politique économique absurde que que
l'on mène aujourd'hui mais qu'on a mené
pendant des décennies je fais une
parenthèse sur les 50 passé puisque
pendant cinq ans on a essentiellement
affronter une crise sans précédent est
plutôt plutôt bien que mal grâce à
nicolas sarkozy mais à part cette
période là on est enfermé dans ce qu'on
appelait jadis la pensée unique dans ce
que monsieur philippe séguin appelé le
minix social dans cette espèce de ronan
semant des renoncements politique devant
devant l'économie est-ce qu'on a
continué ça ça ça m'intéresse avec
l'europe telle qu'elle est politicien
mais justement sur le programme
c'est ce dont vous êtes en train de
parler la toile vous préparer tout ça
programme d'alternance vous par exemple
monsieur guaino vous comment vous
apportez votre pierre à l'édifice
mais moi j'aurai vous est proposé ben je
viens de chez vous je propose je parle
voilà ma pierre à l'édifice je sais pas
trop ce que c'est que c'était difficile
en un cinquième république vous savez
c'est le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui décide du programme
de gouvernement
1 c'est toujours pareil ce qui devrait
vous avez l'air de dire alors qu'au lieu
de paix n'a pas affaire de profs le
président soit élu
on attend d'avoir un candidat des
élections présidentielles mais se disait
tout à l'heure à propos du gouvernement
le président c'est le président qui
détermine la politique de la france même
si dans la constitution du csel promise
c'est le président bon et puis c'est le
candidat à la présidentielle qui
détermine le programme de gouvernement
et le programme d'alternance c'est ainsi
ça a toujours aimé
choisir de nos habitations et j'ai
entendu françois fillon il ya deux jours
dire que l'ump devait se préparer à
toute éventualité de main mais je sais
pas si tu as aussi elle doit se préparer
à toute éventuelle si ça veut dire que
nous sommes appelés à réfléchir ensemble
mais en acceptant notre diversité sens
qu'aujourd'hui il y ait une façon très
efficace de de faire la synthèse la
synthèse elle viendra au moment où nous
devrons candidat mais que nous ayons un
débat d'idées nous l'avons que nous
discutions nous discutons en revanche
l'idée de confier comme ça a été fait il
ya quelques il ya quelques mois à un
comité de dix sages qui sont dont on ne
sait pas d'où ils tiennent leur sagesse
le soin de décrire un décret d'un pseudo
programme pour pour l'ump
ça c'est absurde et d'ailleurs moi j'ai
dit que je ne me sentais pas engagé mais
j'ai vu que ni françois barois ni alain
juppé ne se sentait non plus engagé
c'est le genre d'exercice que les partis
font toujours mais qui donc pin pad qui
n'ont pas de portée
ils n'ont pas de portée pratique nous
devons ce que pour l'instant si déjà
nous arrivions à réfléchir tous ensemble
une somme à réussir et à faire de notre
diversité de notre diversité qui est
grande
oui on va le voir de plus de notre
diversité est une richesse
et bien ce serait déjà alors très bien
on va voir votre diversité sur l'europe
juste un petit mot que de sa mission
impossible
pour manuel valls est ce que vous pensez
que il pourrait y avoir une dissolution
avant la fin du quinquennat mais ça
dépend du prix la situation soit ce
qu'avait alors vous ne souhaitez pas je
pense que si on a si on a une
dissolution dans un quinquennat ça
voudra dire que les choses ont vraiment
très mal et que nos institutions sont
dans un piteux état merci merci beaucoup
nadège valeur perrine tarneaud donc
arriver on va évoquer justement l'un des
grands débats au sein de l'ump mais
comme du tout partie de tous les partis
c'est bien sûr l'enjeu européen qui vous
motive d'ailleurs particulièrement on
l'a compris henri guaino attendus
c'est à vous dans un instant mais
d'abord il faut expliquer ce qui se
passe
avec l'ump qui espère bien sûr quelque
chose pour finir ce débat pour la
transition et oui c'est disent certains
de mes amis avec disait tout va bien une
victoire éclatante oui c'est une grande
victoire électorale mais faut pas se
tromper les français ont manifesté leur
rejet à la fois et fortement du
gouvernement et de la majorité parce
qu'ils sont au pouvoir
mais ils ont aussi marqué leur défiance
vis-à-vis de toute la classe politique
et il nous avons nous avons devant nous
un défi considérable
voilà qui n'est pas seulement le défi du
gouverneur qui est ce que c'est quelque
chose est sûre on assiste à une
confrontation des idées à l'ump sur la
question européenne je fais court
samia de sheer il n'y a pas dans la
marque même de l'engagement de l'ump de
doute sur la nécessité d'avoir une
europe plus forte une rôle fort oui mais
laquelle
la question n'est toujours pas tranchée
à l'ump il pension saint-janvier henri
guaino ancien conseiller de nicolas
sarkozy adresse une lettre au patron de
l'ump
ils protestaient alors contre
l'investiture d'alain lamassoure comme
tête de liste aux européennes en
ile-de-france alain lamassoure un pro
européen convaincu
à l'opposé du discours eurosceptiques
daury guaino henri guaino il est tout
seul il n'a personne derrière lui et
donc moi je vais pas passer mon temps à
parler d'un type qui est tout seul
un débat que la présidence du parti
s'est bien gardée d'arbitré jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui l'ump n'a pas de ligne en
matière de construction européenne et en
matière de projets européens
elle reste écartelée entre la primauté
aux états nations et les partisans des
états unis d'europe qui sont des
héritiers du centre droit venu de feu
l'udf des querelles balayée par la tête
de liste en île de france
il est sûr que désormais l'ump à un
projet clair pour l'europe
nous allons mettre au point demain
mercredi nous allons finaliser le projet
européen de l'ump sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis maintenant deux mois
avec tous les dirigeants de l'ump
alors il y aura toujours quelques francs
tireurs qui seront hostiles ou qui ont
des idées personnelles c'est très bien
meilleur une position générale une
campagne axée sur l'europe de la défense
de l'énergie mais aussi vague bleue
marine
lige sur le thème de l'immigration dite
choisi d'une europe qui maîtrise ses
frontières voilà perrine est avec nous
au penseur perrine tarneaud miss à vos
questions ok brûle de répondre qu'est ce
que vous êtes vraiment tout seul isolé à
l'ump sur votre position soit pas du
tout mais je crois que monsieur
lamassoure connais très mal l'ump
puisque depuis un certain temps oui mais
comme il passait il a passé son temps à
bruxelles ce qui est d'ailleurs tout à
fait honorable puisqu'il était député
européen mais je ne sais pas vous savez
moi ça fait 30 ans que j'appartiens à
cette famille politique en tout cas à
son comme sa composante la plus
importante qui s'appelait jadis le rpr
j'ai contribué modestement l'élection de
deux présidents de la république donc à
l'ump je suis chez moi
mais chez moi je dis ce que j'ai envie
de dire voilà non mais donc je me sens
pas tout seul jeu depuis depuis que j'ai
été élu et je le faisais déjà avant je
sillonne la frange rencontre des
militants je rencontre des élus dont
certains jeux tout se connaît depuis
très longtemps j'ai pas l'impression
d'être tout seul
permettez nicolas sarkozy avait eu
l'intelligence de vouloir réconcilier la
france du oui et la france du non comme
le disait et il cherchait à les chercher
à dépasser cette contradiction
bon là on n'est plus dans le dépassement
de la contradiction on nous sort
monsieur lamassoure qui incarne et après
tout c'est très respectable il ya peu de
gens qui incarne quelque chose en
politique lui il incarne quelque chose
de c'est très simple c'est que c'est
il incarne l'europe d'aujourd'hui celle
qui est en train de se faire sm dont
plus personne ne veut
n'avait pas dit je vous le dis très
clairement aujourd'hui je ne soutiendrai
pas la campagne de monsieur lamassoure
monsieur lamassoure est armé
ça ça vous regarde pas je mettrai je
mettrai pas un bulletin à son nom ça je
peux vous le dire dès aujourd'hui ça
peut faire le buzz qu'on voudra je ne
voterai pas pour l'incarnation d'une
ligne qui est à l'opposé dans seulement
de ce que je pense mais de ce que je
crois être l'intérêt de mon pays
mais c'est pourtant cette ligne à qui va
être retenu par l'usb cette semaine ça
va être un projet de la sélection qui
parle on n'est pas chez staline on n'est
pas au parti communiste
on n'est pas au front national non plus
hein c'est pas personne n'est
propriétaire effectivement je suis un
esprit libre je me suis engagé à partir
des convictions qui sont les miennes sur
l'intérêt de mon pays voilà je préfère
j'aime dans le futur projet alors pour
l'instant je connais pas le projet mais
vous savez la politique c'est des idées
et une incarnation d'abord on choisit
pas un candidat avant d'avoir choisi un
projet là on a fait le contraire
bon ça je suis totalement en tiff à ce
genre de ce genre de méthode bon
monsieur
les autres concurrents sont perçus et
d'alain lamassoure
il aurait été nommé il y aura été
désigné comme second sur la sueur l'anis
après tout ça vous a droit à la
diversité mais là et on le met en tête
de lice sur la liste la plus importante
enfin la famille qu'il a effectué
plusieurs mandats aussi au parlement
remportant aussi je vous de s'appuyer
sur cette expertise là moi je me suis
dit que c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de hans
où dès neuf heures chez les rivaux en 2d
ça n'aurait eu aucune signification
politique et il aurait été reconduit au
parlement et tout le monde aurait été
contents ils auraient pu faire la preuve
de son expertise
mais moi je vais vous dire moi ma
conviction la plus pro fait je ne
cesserai de le répéter dans les semaines
qui viennent
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça alors
ça ne peut pas voilà et si si quelqu'un
veut faire campagne en disant que ça
continue que ça va continuer comme ça je
donne rendez vous à ceux qui font cette
campagne le soir des élections
européennes
mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas premier
bien sûr yard mardi
non tout le monde le dit pas mais les
gens les plus convaincus ils
reconnaissent les faits il y en a il y
en a beaucoup qui reconnaissent ne peut
pas continuer comme ça qu'il faut que ça
change du tout au tout et puis à des
gens qui vous explique on va changer à
la marge que la menace qu'en fera la
même politique que monsieur hollande va
et avec les mêmes résultats
un double échec programmé aux élections
européennes le 25 mai tombant se
décideront au gras il en tirera les
leçons le soir mais bon nous avons un
problème en france c'est que le déficit
nous sommes sous surveillance le cinq
surveillants exactement est ce que ça
vient de se renforcer
est ce que vous attendez de françois
hollande qu'il essaye de négocier avec
bruxelles avec la commission européenne
un délicieux moi j'attends d'eux
le président de la république française
et du gouvernement français qu'il fasse
preuve d'audace
parce que non seulement l'europe ne peut
plus continuer comme ça mais la
situation de la france non plus non plus
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ont dit les
français très bêtement mais ça veut dire
que la commission allait garder il se
passe des choses intéressantes en europe
et dans le monde d'ailleurs des gens qui
ont eu l'audace il y en a il y en a au
japon il ya une défaillance et des pays
en europe et qui ont fait des efforts
budgétaires et qui connaissent un retour
croissance oui bien sûr une sauce un
site mais si tu sais non c'est us est
une blague initial elle a fonctionné en
violant tous les traités tous les
traités elle a su faire mais c'est pas
là vous n'êtes pas le jeu qui a entraîné
ses homologues européens à un moment où
la crise est établie en donnant tout le
monde tout le monde s'est dit oh la la
c'est alors tout ce qui était sacré
toutes les tables de la loi ont été deux
ans d'études à faire je peux finir de
danse effectivement que françois
hollande ne me laissait pas finir bon
voilà il se passe quelque chose en
europe d'intéressant c'est ce que fait
monsieur renzi en italie on va voir ce
que ça donne mais ça c'est une puissance
et une sas et de l'audace sa seule envie
de ne pas continuer toujours sur le même
chemin dans la même ornière
on verra s'ils réussisent et la
politique italienne séance à valence et
la princesse a laissé filer les déficits
oui mais ça c'est extraordinaire vous
êtes dans deux catégories mentales ccc
intenable non c'est intenable
c'est ça de la pire façon de faire et de
la politique et de l'économie
extraordinaire l'économie on peut
raconter n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
et on en a toujours réservé c'est extra
c'est le seul domaine on peut raconter
ma nage
sur un deal était simple intéresse c'est
c'est de retrouver la croissance et de
réduire le chômage de sortir mon pays de
l'ornière et il dit voilà je mets un
plan de 100 milliards sur la table alors
on peut discuter sur la pertinence mais
s'intéresse à 190 milliards de
remboursement de ce que l'état doit aux
entreprises 10 milliards de baisses d
impôts et porte à porte ce projet il ya
une audace il ya un vrai projet on peut
le critiquer mais au moins au moins six
fois ci c'est une jolie en tourisme on
va essayer de changer vous retrouvez pas
cette hôtesse là dans l'action
européenne telle qu'elle est portée au
niveau au niveau de la france nicolas
sarkozy l'avait un peu pire est un peu
d'audace on a laissé le grand on croire
il n'a aucune capacité à s'imposer au
niveau européen françois l'auteur doublé
n'a pas ici je sais pas si on a la
capacité il n'a pas essayé et deezer est
orienté l'europe fait comme monsieur
jospin on avait écrit croissance dans le
dans le traité d'amsterdam il avait
réorienté l'europe une blague
autre chose je voulais vous parler de
moi c'est très important on va pas
continuer comme ça et ce qui va se jouer
dans les élections européennes c'est pas
c'est pas laissez pas leurrer c'est pas
tellement le nombre de députés que
chacun d'entre eux mir c'est la position
c'est la position de chacun face à
l'europe
le jour où il a gouverné est ce qu'on
continue comme ça la question est toute
simple est ce qu'on continue comme ça
pour moi monsieur lama surcoût pour
faillir j'ai la plus grande estime
qu'ils représentent sans doute à lui
tout seul toute ma famille politique il
est le visage de la continuité de
service et moi je me le contrat de cette
continuité
je voulais vous parler du mariage gay en
grande bretagne je voulais faire vous
faire voir cette photo est celle du
bonheur en angleterre ce week-end c'est
le premier mariage gay qui a été célébré
là bas on va voir sans doute la photo
apparaître non la voit pas voilà le
bonheur anglais pourquoi la base selon
voix henri guaino la réforme est passée
sans contestation vous n'auriez pas eu
beaucoup de succès en angleterre comme
opposants au mariage gay et je n'en sais
rien ce que je sais c'est que beaucoup
de beaucoup de dangers qui nous guettent
de là bas sont déjà allés faire
consommer c'est à dire que on peut déjà
faire de la gpa on peut déjà on peut
déjà faire de la pma de façon plus large
qu'en france et que donc l'enjeu n'était
pas le même
tout ça avec l'aval du conservateur mais
écoutez moi je suis pas anglais voilà je
suis pas anglais
il ya des pays déjà il ya des états aux
états unis où on va devant les tribunaux
pour savoir si le l'intérêt de l'enfant
doit primer sur celui du contrat le
contrat de la mère porteuse ou l'
inverse
mais moi je veux pas vivre simplement
dans une société où les choses se
passent ainsi c'est tout moi je suis
jean c est aussi l'union salue aussi
l'union européenne seb et des unions
gays je ne sais pas comment on fait ça
n'arrivera que la liberté est avec toi
rien du tout les droits du groupe
non c'est pas si pas un droit le mariage
est une institution et c'est une
institution non pas privé mais sociale
qui existe depuis qu'il existe des
sociétés organisées elle a pour but de
mettre de l'ordre dans la filiation
voilà je sais j'étais parfaitement
d'accord et depuis longtemps pour qu'on
fasse un contrat d'union civile
en revanche toucher à la filiation à
travers le mariage mais un désordre dans
la société et est renversée valeurs qui
lui permettent de vivre ensemble d'une
manière que je trouve extrêmement
dangereux est ce que ces questions de
société ont pesé dans le scrutin et
municipaux et pas seulement à cause de
la question elle-même et de la manière
dont on s'y est pris c'est à dire de la
façon dont le gouvernement a fait passer
ses réformes en méprisant totalement
tous ceux qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec lui tout ce dont se heurter la
conscience en essayant plat de discuter
pas trouvé de consensus
c'est ça c'est c'est la pire des choses
depuis le début d'ailleurs ce
gouvernement c'est chine
cegid a creusé des fractures terrible et
bien cette facture là elle est très
profonde et très profonde
c'est aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
perrine merci henri guaino la semaine
prochaine notre invité sur un gérard
larcher et pérenno reparlera la de
l'alternance annoncé aux seniors au mois
de septembre
un autre rendez vous électoral de
l'année a très vite